when Stefani sticks up for her man Adam  Levine fired shots at Gwen's beau Blake  Shelton when he tweeted this old  yearbook photo of Blake writing I want  to punch young Blake Shelton's face so  hard he will not shut up Gwen caught  wind of the dish and tweeted Adam you  are so dumb she signed the tweet with  the angry face poop and hear no evil  emojis feel so special as if we needed  more reasons to fall in love with these  two though they have not been shy about  gushing over each other to our cameras I  learned laughing I'm going when it comes  to songwriting already I mean because  she's so brutally honest in her writing  he's so talented at me because I'm like  such a different world  god it's like being with her but you  know when she's all dolled up and we go  places it's always fun for me I love to  keep like maybe we can make each other  smile  Oh No here I go